So let's dig a little deeper into sort
of how we're going to implement some of
those functions, or those features.
First of all, we have to protect
the data that is used by the operating
system, or
the transferred computing base.
It must protect itself.
Remember, one of the requirements we
had is that it should be tamper proof.
So, no one should be
able to tamper with it.
And that's only possible when
it is able to protect itself,
against that kind of tampering.
So let's talk about some
security features of
the trusted operating
systems that you have,
in terms of protecting data and
other kind of resources.
So one thing that we address
in these kinds of systems,
is what is called object
reuse protection.
Think of various kinds of objects or
resources, a memory pages, for example.
Disk blocks.
And so what happens when you allocate
a memory page to one process.
That process completes and
then goes away, and
then that page is allocated
to a different process.
But what happens if that page had
some sensitive data that belonged to
the first process?
This also applies to disk blocks for
persistent data.
When a file is deleted, we may free up
certain blocks where the file data was
stored, and these free blocks are free
to be assigned to somebody else.
And they could be, but there may
be data already in these blocks.
In fact, there is.
The one thing we can do, if we
are concerned about having trust in
the system, is that when a process
is allocating either disk blocks or
memory, then we should
be aware of the fact,
that something could be left behind
in these reusable resources.
Well, what can we do if
something is left behind?
If this the system is trusted,
it can zero out these object
before they get reused.
So before the memory block is given
to the new process, we make sure that
it doesn't haven access to the data
that was stored in that memory block or
page by the last process.
We can zero it out.
If we're talking about a file deletion,
or data that's written out in the disk,
we can override it with various
patterns of zeros and ones.
And we have secure deletion,
for example.
And that's basically writing it one or
more times with some garbage, random
zeroes and ones, to make sure that all
data that was there is no longer there.
And you can sort of carry it
even further for example,
when you discard your disk,
do you actually destroy it,
do you degauss it, or
you can do physical destruction.
Because one of the things order a number
of years ago, a bunch of students at MIT
actually went to some place, and bought
some old PCs at almost no cost, and
then pulled out the discs
in those machines, and
they contained all
kind of sensitive data.
Because even if you, either people
don't delete files, even if you delete,
if you're not doing some of these
things that we discussed here,
which a trusted system should do,
the data would still be there.
And if the disk gets in
the hands of somebody else,
then they will be able to sort
of gain access to the data.
So if you're building a secure system,
you have to worry about this idea
of reuse of objects or resources.
In particular, memory objects,
disk blocks, and how information that's
stored in them by a given process of
the system has to be wiped clean,
before those resources
are re-allocated to somebody else.